claiming that DeSantis attacked Trump
supporters we must overreact
ing that he insulted them we have a
strand in our in our party that views
supporting Trump as whether you are
um a rhino or not and so you could be
the most conservative person since
sliced bread unless you're kissing his
rear end they will somehow call you a
rhinos you're not rooted in principle uh
if all we are is listless vessels that's
just supposed to follow you know
whatever happens to come down the pike
on Truth social every morning that
that's not going to be a durable
movement okay if you didn't have any of
this set up and you didn't have any of
the hand ringing ahead of time and you
heard to Santa say that would you say oh
I can't believe you said that that's
horrible how could he say that no hey
what he's saying is just obvious was de
Santa saying that all Trump supporters
are listless vessels no obviously not